hard work working a little bit harder to
work ethic very hard working go hard
work ethic what work ethic
hello believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs are going to
solve all the major problems of the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how you can
develop an insane work ethic and as
always guys if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below put quotes
around it to other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick for
yourself to enjoy yes I get up at crazy
hours whether it's three o'clock in the
morning by the way when we're talking in
London I wish she kept at 3 because I
had to be on set by 4 I'm sorry by 7 so
whatever time my call time is and I tell
this to studios and directors and our
producers whatever tell my call time so
my call time is at 7 then you back your
clock up for hours and then that's when
I get up and train twice so get my
cardio in and breakfast and I'll go hit
the weights
clanging and banging we call it Jack and
the iron but like what time do you go to
bed I mean you might shoot really late
at night I'm averaging on a movie I
average probably about 5 hours of sleep
you know hard work pays I put in a hell
of a walk all throughout this build up
in the fire I think they're more content
than anybody more content and Fox more
content than ESPN more content than BT
sport more content and everybody under
my grave on my own channels you know I
mean I'm more course from all angles not
just in the gym but I'm building this
media empire and myself and we pumped
out the content I'm very proud a hell
went we consistently daily movies I was
releasing you know from from like a
month ago every single day you know I
mean nobody's doing that so I'm pretty
proud of that and I'm very like the wolf
pays hard work pays me to I put in the
Morgan that's that's boy I am I'm
sitting at the top I put it all on the
line I show up I prefer
mom and I get the results from that I
knew I was wired to be excited about
business how or why I don't know but you
know and there's certain guys they have
the genetics to jump out of the gym
right certain guys you know that you
know when they golf they had the muscle
memory and the discipline you know Dirk
Nowitzki may not be the most talented
guy in the NBA but his discipline and
his focus to do what's necessary to be
successful
he's willing to do and combine it with
being seven feet tall and being skilled
you know it makes him an amazing
basketball player so it's understanding
what your skill set is finding the right
place to use those skills and then going
for it you know will that make you 250
grand it depends if you pick the right
industry but whatever industry you pick
if you outwork everybody if you try to
be a little smarter than everybody if
you try to be a better salesperson and
everybody if you try to be better
prepared than everybody you've got your
best chance because if you don't do it
and somebody else does the I have the
same work like someone's trying to take
it all away from you you know working
actually working like no one's spending
24 hours working 24 hours to take it all
away from you and that's kind of the way
I look at it I remember asking my dad -
I want a new basketball shoes because I
was a basketball junkie back then he's
like well your shoes work if you want a
new pair of tennis shoes you have to go
out there and get a job and I'm like dad
I'm 12 years old and it just so happens
he was playing poker with his buddies
and one of his buddies is like well I
got a job for you I've got these garbage
bags that we distribute you could sell
the door-to-door I'm like okay and it
was when I was selling them and
realizing that I'd like to sell and that
I could sell and that I recognized that
selling was it was about providing the
service and creating value for people
that I knew that I would literally back
then I knew that I could always succeed
I mean I remember I was 16 I think when
I started a stamp company and started
going to stamp shows and trade shows and
just working a little bit harder than
other people and and trading up from one
stamp to the next I remember one time I
started with a quarter and bought a
stamp and left with $50 thinking
if I could do this I could do anything
and and it's not that everything worked
I failed a lot but I never ever felt
like I wouldn't be able to work hard to
have to succeed and so the one thing my
father gave me which was really key was
that work ethic that ability to get
myself up in the morning no matter how
tight I was ah to push myself through
those pain barriers and again the
combination of the loss of a mother at
six and then being sent out to work at
ten we started work at five o'clock in
the morning through the mill ground
being dropped off at 8:45 at school in
the milkman if they had work ethic so
that combination of those two work ethic
and great insecurity was what got me to
what I went to you tend to be incredibly
modest in terms of describing your
talents and you you always seem to
belittle your your abilities to a
certain extent when clearly there
there's a reason why this everything you
do has been working out I was reading
about how you said that to certain
extent that comes from your your punk
rock roots yep there's no other choice
in those days there's no idea of this
makes money there's no idea like this is
my future it was like a week at a time
they have five shows we're going to get
to Sunday and even those days are like
fraught with turbulence and so I never
really saw a future none of us did and
some of us you know didn't make it some
of them are dead and some of them are
just kind of trying to recreate their
past and so I realized that I have to be
very hard-working
because I don't have kind of the ease of
talent and I come from that I think it
is a lot of ways that served me very
well in that I am is kind of hardworking
as I've ever been completely on without
confidence and I have none I don't I
don't want any because I think you turn
your back on the thing and that's when
you get gored is when you think I got
this I never think I got this I think oh
man don't screw this up and I go at
everything like including you and I
sitting here right now I'm trying to be
fully engaged
and that intensity I think has served me
quite well but it comes from punk rock
absolutely and the last boss I ever had
was my boss at haagen-dazs my icecream
job and to this day he still comes to my
shows and whenever I see Steve who got
me my first apartment who believed
living in my car he believed in me
whenever I see him I get all weepy I I
was oh it's good to see you sir Henry
you can call me Steve I can't do that
sir because because he trusted me with
his money and I said let me run your
store I know how to do this I can do
this he's like well if you screw up
you're out of guy said I won't screw up
and I end up being I ran a store and so
it was but it was anger that said I'll
be here all damn week I'll get this
whole thing right I fired a staff and
rehired a bunch of people can really
work and it was out of anger like I'll
be back in four hours to run this $3 and
75 cent an hour job into the ground and
then I joined Black Flag and I thought I
was a hardworking person then you meet
the guys in Black Flag who are so driven
you see Greg Ginn work 23 hour days like
Greg you're still on the phone I know
Greg when did you eat I don't know Greg
when the last time you showered
do we have a shower like the guy we were
not going to be stopped and I kind of go
at that intensity what kind of anything
I do like you're very calm good-looking
young man look at me I'm a spaz sitting
next to York I'm doing an interview with
you okay I'm sweating ma'am and so but I
like it going to the airport like ten
miles out and so it's but it's anger
that has informed kind of my life and
unflatteringly a sense of vengeance
every damn person who said I wouldn't be
anything I'm crushing them every day
everybody I had to endure in any band I
was in every day into a powder yeah
thank you and I wish them no ill I just
wish to shine brighter and if it burns
my body to a crisp I'm happy to go right
now
go hard
and then when you think you're going
hard go harder like that's really is its
hustle you know I mean it's nothing like
that you can't you can't put enough work
in every single day and not get better
at you know what I mean like if you want
to be good at something you know I mean
like you can't just like not like do it
every day and not get better this is
very with music the same learning how to
play an instrument so if you spend your
time practicing your craft like you know
that's really it just you know is it
because nowadays like with the internet
everything is so accessible and you know
everybody in the world is a rapper you
know I mean everybody's putting music
out so it's like how do you stand out
quality is always going to matter but
also being different you can't try to be
different
yeah I mean but you just gotta be
yourself how is it different today and
doing your show like night than it was
10 years ago
are you more instinctive are you more do
you think less about it yes do
muscle-memory it is used to it like you
office want you crunch down your and
you're constantly trying to learn your
cheer you're constantly you're still
thinking but your ratio thinking to
acting is very different you know you're
at the beginning I was thinking about it
this much you know in my cognitive brain
and then there was this much just
whatever a thin read of talent you have
is there and then you're thinking about
the rest and then over the years I think
you know they always say the reptile
brain the reptile portion of your brain
is where you you know respiration
heartbeat right that's the stuff that
even if you're not done conscious it's
still working
I really believe a lot of my talk show
or comedy instincts are now in my
reptile brain that you could knock me
out and my heart would still be I'd
still breathe and I'd still be asking
Lindsey Lowen yes in stupid questions
you have become some way as you part of
your deities become part of your DNA
yeah I mean I think a lot of it is you
have to have some ability but then it's
just how much will I really do think
there's just a people underestimate it
doesn't sound sexy it doesn't sound cool
how much do I wanted work ethic you know
and just how badly
you want it and there have been you know
many times in the you know throughout
the years of doing my show where I've
thought you could shoot me in the chest
before I walk out there and I'll still
walk out there and do that show and then
I'll come backstage and die but we're
doing that show the interesting thing
for me to talk to you and what makes you
so fascinating is the talent that you
see on the screen but but at the same
time there is a certain innocence and
yet a certain power and it seems to me
it's it's both artists and also business
thank you would you believe that yeah my
right that's that worked very hard to
make to make not true so thank you that
it's okay thank you because without
gaining some sort of control over the
business I lose some control or for the
over creative which is most important
how I know you control of the business
the more you can give flower to the
creative exactly I'll give wings to the
creation yeah so I used to stay out of
it I don't care I know I am in earnest
in it I don't need it you know and this
is my business now you know it is
important at my agent that when agent
always says I'm as I'm his only client
asking for call them back as soon as he
because it's my business and I thanks
major agencies you only klonda calls him
back to city Utley it means I is amiss
calling probably the only I returned
emails or return phone calls because you
want to know what the options there are
yes I've worked really hard to build
this and I want to continue building it
and it's my business my personal
business so I don't understand how
people do slack I have a disease I'm a
workaholic and I like being an alcoholic
I just can't give it up
I've been unwell for two weeks and I
feel unwell you know so I can go to work
because I can't go to work I get was if
I sit in one place I'm stressed
the reason I'm not fidgeting too much is
because I'm on but otherwise I hate
sitting in one place I some work has to
be given to me I
with my wife and my children keep
telling me you know you work 20 years
round-the-clock why is it doing this I
don't think I need the money I don't
think I'm greedy for more Fame I'm doing
okay I can do one serving two years and
be happy with it but I'm just not happy
I tell everyone if I'm not working I'm
depressed so I don't know if it's a
curse or the blessing maybe at the end
of it all when we die God will say did
you work
I say yes a lot oh damn you go to hell
because I didn't want anyone to work oh
it would be all your work that's really
nice because I wanted everyone to work
so I don't know one of them is going to
be right
but I just keep working I think I have
this fear that you have very few days in
life and you need to cram it up with a
lot of things you need to further fill
it with so many things in it that you
don't have space for life it should be
like that
I what I'm not working like it you only
I get depressed I get sad I don't drink
I'm not a philosopher not a player that
I like loneliness I hate being alone and
I hate being with people at times
I'm unsocial I'm very odd with people so
what happens is I have replaced people
with work in my life because when I'm
working I would lot of people and there
are people I can interact with because
somewhere there is a wall that I'm not
interacting with them socially I am
interacting them through this common in
a goal that is the work so I can discuss
with her or discuss with him and your
friends for that moment many of my
filmmaking colleagues complained that
after the film is over you don't talk to
us I can't explain to them I don't have
anything else to say I love you I miss
you but i miss you through the work I
don't I mean I'm very fond of a lot of
people a lot of people I love like
family and I I can't pick up the phone
and talk to them I can't socialize with
them I can't sit and chat with them but
when we're working I I can just be with
them so I don't know what a sort of I
have replaced loneliness depression and
people good work
when you comes from the working-class
background that I come from
I feel guilty at 10 to 5 if I'm not in
the office I know that might sound
strange to you but that's a cosmetic
that I have to be half dead not to not
go to work it's a kind of a work ethic
that's built into me yeah but
nevertheless having said all that the
weekends that was it it's over
switch off like Friday night as you got
back from the office or from the work or
from the factory or whatever matter what
was buzzing around in my head it was off
like a light switch and that's it done
let it interfere very rarely let it
interfere with the weekend and then
Monday morning bang back on it again as
if you should click the switch on again
so I have a bit of discipline in that
respect yeah thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know what was your biggest takeaway from
this video what are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down the
comments below I'm super curious to find
out so thank you guys again for watching
I believe in you I hope we get to me to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon